una petición de auxilio que fue
escuchada el consejo permanente de la
Organización de Estados Americanos se
reúne para analizar la situación en Perú
es el salvavidas que pidió el presidente
Pedro Castillo ante el aluvión
institucional que se le viene encima
ahora el congreso quiere cambiar ese
artículo para poder
instrumentalizar la nueva modalidad del
golpe de estado
pidiendo al tribunal constitucional una
interpretación distinta a su letra los
artículos 17 y 18 de la carta
democrática Interamericana que Castillo
pide invocar buscan proteger a los
Estados miembros de amenazas al legítimo
ejercicio del poder y facultan al
secretario general de la oea y al
consejo permanente a adoptar
resoluciones para la preservación de la
institucionalidad democrática el
miércoles el fiscal a cargo del proceso
contra Castillo seguro que tenía todos
los elementos para probar la existencia
de una organización criminal en el
gobierno nacional
tienen el número de aproximadamente 190
el elemento exploratorio nosotros que
Hemos cumplido con agotar la diligencias
preliminares y poner a consideración del
Congreso la denuncia constitucional es
un mecanismo que permite determinar si
personas con inmunidad cometieron
delitos durante el ejercicio de sus
funciones pero no es una de las tres
causales previstas en la Constitución
para revocar el mandato de un presidente